[Music]
hey babe
hey babe hey babe
hey this is sal volcano and krista
stefano and welcome to another episode
of
hey babe um yeah so uh
dude i um you know we were talking
before
i didn't even tell you this story about
when
my my kid's mom when her father died did
i ever tell you that story
it's hilarious i feel like it would ring
a bell i
as of right now i don't think so thing
about brooklyn the thing about like
growing up in brooklyn and like having
like brooklyn owned like mafia places
yeah is like you know these guys
negotiate they have deals this is like a
real thing that all true we're about to
say happen
yeah i just watched a netflix like fear
city or whatever it is one of the best
things i've ever seen in my life
isn't it crazy though the taps the
wiretaps and all that stuff
fantastic yeah okay so we go to the
funeral you know obviously
you know my to the funeral home my kid's
mom is really upset and uh you know
father died tragic whatever
you know horrible and um and so she says
look can you talk to this funeral guy
it was a you know an old school italian
guy's funeral home on fourth avenue in
in in brooklyn in parkland sure so we
sit down
first of all he offers us like
cappuccino espresso
coffee decaf water micellar cannolis
whatever you guys want you know
he's dressed to the knot he's got like a
you know like a ten thousand dollar suit
on
you know he hasn't unbuttoned the top
button ever in his life yeah he goes um
it's definitely a gold pinky ring
figurine yeah
he goes um so we sit down and he's uh
he's you know we're talking he goes what
kind of casket does she want let me ask
you this let me ask you that
and i'm like yeah and then and he goes
just out of curiosity because this that
this happened
this happened in december uh i'm sorry
january or february of 2017 trump was
elected
november of 2016. he goes you said
curiosity goes let me ask you something
he goes the man you know the man who
passed away on god and he must have said
god you know
uh uh he said the man who passed away at
my respects he must have said it like a
hundred times
he was like he's like my respects he
goes who did he vote for
in the last election and we were like
you know and my kid's mom was like you
know i don't see why that's important
he goes well i'm just saying who did he
vote for i just you know
guy's dead you know tell me we voted for
him and we were like
okay and then i said um i said should i
just tell him like whatever
and she was like i mean i guess and i
was like you know and at that point
two months after like you didn't know if
you could be open about it yet
i was like you know he voted for for
trump and
he goes that man outside right now voted
for donald trump
and like you could see like you didn't
know like his emotion yet like
you could see he was like welling up
you're like is this guy mad is this guy
happy
he goes i'm gonna tell you what i'm
gonna do right now he goes first of all
that guy voted for a true american hero
he goes and i and he and he served in
the military the the my
kids um father served in the military
he's like hey served in
uh he goes he served in the military so
yeah he goes okay because i'm not
supposed to do this unless they pay for
it goes i'm gonna get the
full i'm gonna get full uh american flag
ceremony i'm gonna get the marines here
and we're gonna we're gonna play um
whatever that song is on the way out
bro my grandfather oh thank you he goes
also on top of that what i'm gonna do
free of charge he goes
if you ask me to give you money i'm not
going to give you any money he said he
goes if he asks to pay me i'm not going
to accept your money
it is on the house i'm going to put a
make america great again wreath
in the casket
so he could i swear to god so he said so
he can enjoy the afterlife
with that wreath wow my kid's mom's like
i really don't want
that in the casket like i'm not you know
well yeah even regardless of politics
it's like
the casket is sacred yeah it should be
whatever the family wants
yeah we don't want it okay so we said i
don't want and then he goes he goes i'm
so happy voted for
so happy voted for trump because we had
a family in here last night he goes you
know a couple he's hated
hey babe he's saying this like while
he's negotiating my kid's mom is like
crying
he's like he's like these liberal [ __ ]
he's like he's like guess what
he goes um he was like i was having a
discussion
he goes i was having a discussion with
this guy he goes
he go and go he goes i'm having a
discussion with this liberal guy he goes
everybody's freaking he goes last night
they're all crying in here because trump
won
i'm like no they're probably all crying
because their loved one is dead
they're in the funeral home like what
are you talking about he's like so out
of touch
he's like dude i mean talk about being
first to market with making america
great again wreaths
yeah like for the cast kid like that was
like that was that was foresight
yeah no well no make america great again
was his campaign slogan in
what do you mean like but he had reits
available for burial oh
right all right yeah you had the product
oh yes yes yes that's true yeah
that's because maybe i guess people
maybe asked for that they're asked for
it
but but so he says um he goes yeah he
goes i did uh
he goes i did um you know these liberals
yesterday goes
i'm talking to a guy and i'm telling him
i'm going look
why don't you come in here tomorrow i'll
make you a deal right now it says this
guy goes i'll make a freaking deal right
now
he goes why don't you come in here
tomorrow he goes go home watch the news
wherever you like freaking anderson
cooper whatever he's just assuming
yeah he goes anderson cooper whoever you
like he goes why don't you go and give
me
one thing that hillary clinton that's
done that's right
and one thing that donald trump's done
that's wrong and he goes
real hard factual evidence he said if
you come in with one thing
hillary did right and one thing donald
trump did wrong
i'm to give you this funeral for half
price
i swear to god he's telling me as she's
like
sobbing and he's just like going off i'm
like just tell me how much the casket
cost
and he's going crazy and he's telling me
this story goes he goes i'm going to
tell you if you could do one thing that
hillary did right one thing donny
did wrong i'll give you the funeral for
half price he goes guess what kid
they paid full price because they
couldn't tell me one thing
that based in actual fact that hillary
did wrong
that hillary did right and that was like
wow dude and then
and then i mean i get it everything's
politically charged but why is it
permeating down
to the future i know it's crazy i had
enough for politics i've had enough
yeah oh this guy's cry they do it me too
me too
and he goes and he goes um and then and
then so that was the night though
let's say wednesday night thursday is
you know the the wake
like you know the wake open from nine to
twelve let's say and then he was getting
buried in the
buried in the um you know cemetery
so the family says goodbye you know like
whatever given the private time family
says goodbye
hantagon he goes in when about to close
the casket and
proceeds to put a make america great
again hat on the bottom
no no no on nobody no yeah one of my
kids mom's sister's like
we're pleased respectfully asking you to
not put anything else on his body
i can't i i i can't even
believe it i swear like i you know i i
hate to be rude because
you know i know but it's like i i'm
sitting there what kind of
i mean like dude i see him
i see him unlocking something on the
casket and then moving this guy's head
up
just moving the guy's head to try to fit
the hat
on the head how could this person
anything i mean i guess he thinks he's
doing something noble
you can't touch i mean i guess he's the
one who put him in the suit and stuff
already but
like so he's feeling like he could take
some liberties there but like you can't
how is this guy's business like you
can't just
touch and dress other people's
decease he's like a mafia guy he's a
mafia old-school italian mobster they
don't play by the rules they don't care
he was telling me stories about like
he's like you know how many times and
he's like my family's had this funeral
in 50 years because you want to know how
many times
i mean he's like how many times i go
this is like while the funeral is going
on he was like talking to me and another
guy
he's like how many times i'm sitting
here one of these guys brings in a dead
body
just killed him i got to get rid of it i
was like what do you mean how many times
like non-funeral related like one of his
friends like he was saying like his
friendship
because i'm because they think because
i'm he's like oh all of a sudden i'm a
mortician
now i could freaking cut up bodies and
dispose of them he's like people are
crazy i was like they are
oh my god that is wild yeah and then he
was one of those guys where like
he kept asking me if i wanted cappuccino
i kept saying no and then he said if
i ask you for cappuccino one more time
i'm starting to get a little upset like
you don't want my cappuccino
so i was like i'll take a cappuccino
like i just didn't want it i had too
much caffeine it makes my stomach hurt
he's like how many times are you going
to say no to my cappuccino it's like
what do i do i disgust you
that's that's crazy dude dude yeah that
is crazy yeah man so i just was like
i'm like all like these you know when i
watch these fear city documentaries or
anything mafia related stuff i always
think about that guy
where i'm like you know but it's then
it's interesting because it's like
i wonder because i knew you know her dad
well of course you know it's my child's
grandfather
he loved donald trump so it's like maybe
he was looking down from above like up
keep put the hat on yeah i mean i think
it's like i i
i never really i never really want to
judge a book by its cover but i do
notice older
like a lot of older people more
conservative that's natural my parents
it's an odd thing like like a lot of
people in my family i have some liberal
and some conservative with my family
yeah like a normal family like normally
yeah but um it's getting harder to talk
about i never talked politics in my
family to be honest and no do i want to
now oh yeah um
not that we disagree on every last thing
i also it's a shame that we have to
assign a bucket
with politics like i can't just like
have some views here and somebody i hate
signing because now the culture we live
in you assign yourself to a bucket and
then the other bucket
literally you get completely disregarded
nothing you say matters nothing you can
contribute to the conversation matters
that's how everyone's going so it's like
i'm not going to assign myself to
anything leave me alone i don't want to
be judged by you and i want to talk
i don't care what you think i know that
you're i know that may not be a big deal
to you but i just i have to i wouldn't
be a good friend if i didn't tell you
this
i got spinach in my teeth you've had it
in your that's not the product you do
have especially your teeth but that's
not what i'm concerned about
you have the right the sock that says
r on the left foot i can see it from
under here that says r right
i think this is a right so you do have
the socks on the wrong foot
i don't know if you care no i do care
now it's kind of it's going to bother me
do you want to show your feet to the
camera or is that a hidden thing
the r yeah the r is here on the left
foot so
honestly though i would really prefer
that you told me about the spinach like
while a while back and not to r in the
end of spinach it's it's in a very it's
in the a
back back back tooth i don't think it's
concerning at all i don't think it's
going to come up on camera it's the
other side
and what's song we were talking about
before is remember we were talking about
you know jesus h christ when people say
jesus h christ where does the age come
from
holy they say jesus holy christ
somebody deemed that h jesus his middle
name was holy oh you
you found that i googled it ah wow i
didn't know
you never knew never knew i always
wondered yeah it's educational the
podcast too and then we said
and then we said you know it doesn't cut
the mustard we found that that's not
from the word
that's not from mustard at all that's
from doesn't cut the muster
m-u-s-t-e-r which is a military term for
you know if your
bed is nice and tight and your shoes are
shined
right that's the muster that's the
mustard yeah your mustard on tonight you
look good today
i want to be you know we i want to be in
athleisure but i
also feel like i'll i just don't want to
look so raggedy
i don't know because i all i do is we
wear our sweats so this feels like we
have a little date
yeah we got a little i get i feel like i
get dressed up for you i know i
shouldn't i gotta
start now wearing pants because no no
because my thighs are big and i'm 230
pounds
i feel bad about it i'm i'm wrong i'm
gonna i make a pledge next uh next steps
i i will be
short set a t-shirt yeah i'm gonna come
in jeans yeah
[Laughter]
so wait wait oh you know what i was
saying too you know you didn't tell me i
had spinach in my teeth
yeah this reminds me of something and i
can't throw stones but
i dated a girl one time right and it
annoyed the hell out of me but
she she would text a lot uh when she
texted me she would write
the word hysterical she'd misspell it
how would you spell it
h-y-s-t-e-r-i-c-l-e
stereo hysterically hysterical and
i was like oh like it just bothered me a
bit and then i was like i'll fix this
i'll write her back
i know wasn't it hysterical but i'll
write it the correct way
and then she'll pick up on it it'll
never happen again lo and behold
like fast forward like six months i'm
not kidding you
uh she she said hysterical a lot that
was like one of a good go-to words like
people say like
you know whatever like legitimately or
like or literally right she said
it was hysterical a lot so she i was
always getting bombarded with it she
didn't correct it
and every single time she said it i
doubled back every time
i'm talking dozens and dozens and dozens
of times dozens
in in months and she never spelled it
right back the way right and honestly i
like probably broke i think i think i
think i ended it with her because of
this
i never said anything because so that
was like almost like not telling her i
couldn't bring myself to tell them
like it was like it was like the spinach
my dad still to this day
yeah if he says like you know um would
you want to go to the yankee game he
spells it w-o-o-d
no yeah and he's just he's just doing it
he would he does
w-o-u-l-d doesn't exist so he would
would would you would you care would you
would that annoy you
if someone would you would you say
anything it annoyed me why did it annoy
me what is in my brain
that i couldn't handle that after a few
months it's okay like it's like the
whole your verse your y-o-u-r versus
y-o-u-r-e
not that i don't think if you're not
using it properly
it makes you oh this person's stupid
because they didn't know it's your verse
but the people who do who are very good
who never get your versus your own and
who know how to use it
right in the context tells me that they
are a little bit above average
smart yeah and that they're a caring
person yeah so someone who's spelling
hysterical wrong yeah
on purpose is like are they not as
intelligent as they thought
or do they just not care enough to
change it and then that they're also
probably they're both problems okay so
that's not
on me i don't think so all right no
because you're you're like i feel the
same exact thing with you
and normally you're you're like i'm all
over it i'm aware when i write it but
sometimes you're just writing and
but i will tell you this i misspelled
something i do a you or your accent in a
text no matter who even to you i will
follow it up with an asterisk
and the correct yours thousands i will
follow it up every time because i don't
want you
to go off and start i plant a seed in
you that i'm that person that you just
described 100 percent
how over the top i am with it 100 me too
i would never i never ever ever ever
ever
ever let that go by intentionally
there's been times unintentional where
i'm texting and driving don't do that
kids
where you send the wrong you're i do
mess up there versus there more than i'd
care to
share yeah but we are in a podcast so i
will share i mess it up a lot
wow yeah wow and you how do you know you
go back and you re-read
and then you see that you didn't do it
justice if i say
hey sal i'm coming over i'll be right
there
is it because it's personal is it
t-h-e-i-r
or is it t-h-e-r-e cause we're talking
about going to a place
what the hell was that did you oh okay
did you no so there there is a place
there is t-h-e t-h-e-r-e is place this
place
t-h-e-i-r is possessive if you say
you're i'm coming to their place
it's t-h-e-i-r but if you're going there
whereas there is a noun
then that's t-h-e and then you know then
then you got you're there they are they
well
the apostrophe-re it's so easy because
you just make the apostrophe and and
it's the word
r no but they are but it's not their
t-h-e-i-r
is possessive yeah their house
their they are is not they are but
usually contraction
isn't that possessive when you do an s
right yeah well this is
english english it's funny because it's
podcast goes wherever the
babe let's go hey babe
exactly no because i i um i will tell
you i'm going to tell you something
tell me he's going to sound about to sit
down and tell me something let's say
something right now
i have a a good
interpersonal human being to human being
iq
an emotional iq actually i'm going to
take any further you have one of the
best
emotional iqs i've ever been around in
my life not in my
start of comedy in my life since 1984.
that is so kind
and i mean it i genuinely mean it all
right very high personal iq
very very very very not an iq not like
you and emotional like
emotional like self-awareness yes all
very self-aware yes well thank you very
very much i take that to heart yeah
yeah so i i feel like i'm good with
reading people
and with you know understanding how to
act like that right
i also was book smart i did i did well
in school i got a's and stuff like that
and i
i i did even had a scholarship to
college
partial so i'm not trying to make like
i'm dumb but i am
actually i don't know a lot about things
like a lot like you know contraction
english i'm pretty decent that math i'm
pretty decent but when you talk about
geography
history right things that we you shine
right
i don't know how you remember these
things i wish i could i haven't
committed into memory
i do look back and i think my education
system failed me
right um i think they they like they
just like
i don't know if it was a little bit of
them like they didn't teach us great
or also like it's always just about
memory like
remember this and tell me these things
and remember them and then you go and
you remember them for the test and then
they go away
they don't teach you in a way that makes
you if you're not
insanely interested like you are that
makes you retain and
put a practical world application on the
stuff that you're studying right so
but it's history they're just like just
remember this stuff and
repeat it back to me right but it's
never like a discussion where you're
like oh i see this i see that it's like
read this chapter in a textbook no what
what are the what are the
you know whatever you want to call it
the mason dixon line or the
order right i mean anything you can
think of like um
just the bill of rights or you know
anything like that it's like it's always
just like
remember them say them and that's it and
then that's it and and i didn't remember
that stuff
i don't like that that stuff in history
either as much but i love
wartime like when you talk you say you
got to try this peanut butter from
saratoga
yeah i said let me tell you about
saratogas the turning point in american
revolutionary war
i said you know without without us
winning the battle in saratoga then
france would have never entered the war
we didn't ever
we never wanted penance yeah that's just
what i know about saratoga i tell you
what i know about saratoga yeah
horse races yeah and peanut butter the
saratoga shout out to them because
they're a good company i i saw them at a
street fair or a holiday street fair
saratoga peanut butter
i love them the pieces again we just do
ads on the show without having it
we don't get paid for it but i have no
no less than five jars in my house at
all times
one lucky fan is going to get a jar
saratoga peanut butter uh
when we um when we think of a contest
for it yeah blizzard butter sour toga
peanut butter yeah
i mean i'm going on their website
immediately and do you have a promo code
can i put it inside
i swear to god i have nothing i just it
was the union square 50 for a peanut
butter but let me tell you something
though this is
small batch artisanal family made with
and they're huge varieties
there's like 10 different varieties and
they're low in carbs and sugar
and they're all natural it's a healthier
7 grams of protein 6 net carbs that's
nothing that's nothing and that's that's
blizzard
that's on the high end if you go to the
other peanut butters those numbers are
dropping in half
really they drop chillin chocolate
blizzard butter i mean this is right up
my alley monkey boy they need to change
that name
um plain jane creamy uh adirondack jack
which i did see in south cumberland yeah
and the slow burn i got that one i have
the adirondack jill
i used to add the gingerbread one uh
because
what happens is especially if you're
doing like like it's low carb
i mean we really just do commercials for
people we are not affiliated with
whatsoever
they they might see this and send me a
jar of peanut butter that's 8.50 that's
still not worth what i just gave them
no i'm not it's nothing against you now
i'm turning on them how dare these
people
how dare these people potentially see
this and hit me up with one eight dollar
jar of peanut butter yeah
we just maybe we could have potentially
just got you a hundred people to buy
i should have we just got you a g we
should have a stake in the company at
this point
saratoga doesn't want to cough up what
they owe us yeah then you know what
maybe they weren't as good as we saw but
at the very least at the very least
make us a peanut butter with our name on
it oh
a hey babe flavor peanut butter maybe we
can combine with them i once did this i
almost did this with mcclure's pickles
one time no they're out of detroit me
and q at a podcast we love the pickles
they contacted us and said they would
make a small batch run
with our flavor and they never did but
it is what it is now saratoga has a
has it has a chance to write that wrong
saratoga
don't be like mcclure's pickles also if
mcclure's pickles hears this i'm still
mentioning you
you send stuff here's what i'm going to
tell you right now about the saratoga
peanut butter company
the same way your city was the turning
point of the revolutionary war you could
be the turning point of this podcast
because we're thinking about stopping it
and it's up to you you peanut butter
that's the you stupi
peanut peanut butter peanut butter if i
was on another podcast i would have said
a word
yeah we're trying not to curse too much
hey baby so we can get it
so we can get sponsors so we can like
saratoga saratoga peanut butter company
no so
i met so i went to the union square
holiday market and the guy is there and
it's the guy that makes it like i think
yeah and he was like and he gives you
the sample they once you get a sample
somebody things that we say so casually
because you said that you said you went
to the union square holiday market and i
said that's what sal does that's what i
love to do
and then but the people at home say
these are again two gay men yeah
this is their pocket yes and we support
it and it's just it's just what it is
um dude speaking of peanut butter did i
ever tell you
about the food fight that i got into no
okay okay again this happened three
years ago okay
real story i go to the supermarket i'm
getting one bag of supermarket
i was told to go to supermarket my
daughter was two years old
to get almond milk okay so i get i'm
getting almond milk
i don't know why she wants to shout out
to blue diamond shout out blue diamond
yeah
or almond breeze actually i've got
almond breeze on it yeah yeah almond
milk uh
lemons um cheerios and then i had to get
uh
a carton of blueberries okay so that's
why i just think
on the way there though to the
supermarket there's a a a bar that we
like
and i called uh you know bar restaurant
and i called and my family wanted three
cheeseburgers three cheeseburgers
american cheese tomatoes
all that so i get three cheeseburgers
okay order it the guy says three
cheeseburgers repeats to me twice
okay i go in go to the supermarket go to
this restaurant
i saw hey you know i called in the order
for chris about 25 minutes ago you know
three cheeseburgers he goes
he brings out the bag goes there you go
it's one cheeseburger wrapped in a bag i
ordered three cheeseburgers with
fries and sodas and all that he goes you
told me one cheeseburger
oh god i said i specifically called i
said
i i believe i spoke to you yeah i spo i
told you you know what you wanted
three cheeseburgers deluxe you think you
had a stroke at that moment and said one
instead of three that's what i came in
expecting three you're lying are you
lying is that what he's saying that's
what i said i said oh did i just
neglect two members of my family
you know at dinner time i know that
specifically said and i said you know
what why don't you say that hey babe
you go get the cheeseburgers i'm getting
the almond milk
you know i ordered three
cheeseburgers right with sweet potato
fries any cheesecake don't tell nobody
he says you ordered one that's why i
repeatedly already ordered one if you
want
two more you're going to have to wait
with that because i was so agitated
and to god because it was um not in a it
wasn't a platter so it wasn't in one of
those like silver things
it was just a wrapped cheeseburger and
paper i take the cheeseburger out
and i throw it at the guy's chest i
swear
that hits not even at the wall so to god
because i was so angry he lets the
cheeseburger hit off and he gets moving
back
to god again with that a waiter's coming
behind him
with somebody else's meal mozzarella
sticks french fries
drinks he takes a handful of french
fries and throws them at me
no sal i swear
i then reach into the bag take a handful
of the blueberries that i had
and throw them at them with that another
waiter comes in
breaks it up says please stop throwing
food at everybody i leave i'll
never come back to the baby place again
i ordered three cheeseburgers
i leave i come back i i just go back to
the house
i have a nice thud on the chest with
cheese cheeseburger could get some
weight behind it you know yeah
nice bud so through the blueberries
through the cheeseburger i come back i
have half a carton of blueberries
the almond milk and then i had some out
because you know again
you just don't notice i had a a shirt
like a like a little button-down shirt
with a little pocket i had a french fry
sweetheart
in my pocket that he had thrown from the
other guys from the other guy's thing
maybe it was more no maybe i must maybe
my daughter was younger because i had to
run back might have been four and a half
years ago then
oh god was that okay i've gotten into
okay
there's been times where i was at like a
red like a drive-in and then like
you know road rage and someone does
something
and then you roll down a minute and i've
gotten into like screaming matches with
people right
um and then like in the middle of it
feel how ridiculous it is
and like either one of us or both or
whatever would be like
just like kind of laugh whatever did he
did you did you get to that point at all
with him like we're like
with two men throwing cheese at each
other or did you was it hostile
anger it was like angry angry angry like
i had nothing to throw
did you laugh when you walked out you're
like i just whipped blueberries it was
one of those things where when the
cheeseburger was probably equally
distant from my hand to his chest i was
like this is stupid chris why'd you do
this
but it was already flying you know like
i scaled back
you play ball i mean you you yeah you're
a guy you're an athletic fella it was
like henry rowan gardner when he looked
back at his arm i'm like oh no
and then i just whipped it and then he
with that
just coincidentally threw the food that
was going to table seven
sweating at me and then i kind of ducked
down and then my hand you know i the bag
was right there
one motion i just threw the blueberries
you won that you won you initiated
and ended it yeah and i got thrown out
and then the interesting thing though is
that place still to this day when my kid
you know and my mom live is on the
corner i see i walk past and now with
the
coronavirus open tables outside i see
this guy every day
that's wild yeah i wish i could hear the
sound the burger against the chest made
but you know because i'm i'm
imagining it yeah but you know how
infuriating that is when they tell you
no you only ordered one i hate it
it's happened to me it's happening
people when you deliver and you call you
like you forgot the
i'm like you never said that i'm like
really i didn't i read it off
do you know how meticulous i am yeah i i
it's actually a curse i live with a
curse yeah
and how how how much i had to dot every
t and cross every other yeah yeah
whatever
reverse it whatever yeah but uh and then
they say
it's not even like first of all let's
say i didn't say it customer always
right
that's it what do you get you get to
sell too much like she's pleasant
you know but but like honestly like to
what end do you have to prove
someone wrong anyway you should be like
oh was it okay
yeah our bed i i ain't here i'm sorry
unfortunately you know because the
kitchen's all backed up may have to be a
15-minute wait i apologize
something let me flip the other side i
worked at a bar restaurant for a cool
decade
okay and there are people that came in
that i
really really really didn't i wished
them light harm at least
yeah yeah fall up the stairs just people
that don't know how to treat other
people but not never
like if you went in politely and said i
think i ordered the three i'd be like oh
my god i'm so sorry
right but there's people that just don't
like you know what i mean like they just
i remember this isn't one of them but i
i'll never forget this one like
a woman um uh wanted shrimp
and um we had i think we had it but the
lunch special had ended
and uh i mean this is exactly what
happened okay
yeah i'm not like making it like this
i'm not this is this is
this is how she said it so i went up and
i i only bartended but in the daytime if
i ever worked a day shift and cover
someone
there's not a lot of people there so you
come from behind the bar and also be the
waiter right right
so i went and then uh she said i could
she should i can get scrimps
not even shrimp she i guess she was
southern i don't know like
scrimps scrimp and not even because
shrimp and plural shrimp is not shrimp
to shrimp shrimp
fish fish shrimp shrimp doesn't matter
how many shrimp you have you never me
that she didn't even subscribe to that
because she didn't say scrimp scrimp and
scrimp is plural yeah so she added the s
and took out the asian threw in a c
and she said i can get scrimps right and
that's also a statement not a question
right so i i was like fine i know
exactly what she wants and i said i'm so
sorry
but the shrimp was on the earlier menu
we don't have the shrimp right now and
she just
got up flipped out and she started
screaming like i can't believe this you
gave me the wrong menu and i was like
no this is says lunch and it's the right
menu but you looked at the wrong thing
and she's like i can't believe i can't
get scrimps
and i was just like i am i mean i can go
back and see but we might have run out
of them because it's only offered
and she just kept screaming but i'll
never forget it because to this day when
i'm like
it's actually like you know how we were
like yolanda vega
she just made that little tweak and we
just say it to ourselves kids say it and
everything
and you know how you said someone you
said to me that someone that would stop
they told me like yolanda vegas
to this day i i loved the exchange like
i actually loved the woman
right you know what i mean but like like
i i but i was just like wow she went
hot under the collar about this right
what happened but nothing i i
did they have the shrimps i don't
remember it so i'm not going to say yes
or no because i don't remember that but
i will never forget what she said and to
this day in my life
there's sayings that come to the
forefront of my mind like i'll be in my
house
alone like i'll be vacuuming or in the
shower and i just go
i could get scraps because i just love
it it's just so fun
i could get scraps a lot of people been
asking me chris what's your nicotine
alternative i mean people have been
coming up to the streets say what are
you what's your nickel team
people have been coming up to me in the
streets lately out of nowhere be like
hey chris i've seen the podcast i like
the podcast what you got going on with
sal what's your nicotine alternative
it's crazy they do that in these times
yeah they do that in these times with
yeah
and i say what do you mean what's my
nickname because it's so important yeah
it's so important and i say obviously
it's lucy dot co
it's the lucy nicotine brand lucy.co
promo code hey babe at checkout that's
all you need to know i notice you're
saying co
not yes that's important they left off
the m
for lucy dot co c o
promo code hey baby and they have all
sorts of flavors
uh for the for this chewing gum if they
got wintergreen no they don't no they do
what why is that a big deal i'll tell
you what's not what i'll tell you it's a
big deal pomegranate they don't have a
pomegranate
pomegranate flavor nicotine
alternative you got some palm breath on
you we know you're trying to quit
quit do they let me ask you something
i'll be sold right now because i'm in
the christmas spirit i'm in the holiday
spirit
do they have cinnamon they got cinnamon
what are you nuts
cinnamon of course they have our
listeners can go right now
to lucy.com put in the promo code hey
baby you're gonna get 20
off of everything the gum and then the
lozenges too because they have cherry
ice thousands
wow because i got a little bit of a
tickle in my throat what's coming up the
new year right yes what are we saying
we want to quit the bad habits yes you
want to quit devices lucy.co
right now is not making it any easier i
mean come on and and you know the
product does contain nicotine derived
from tobacco
and nicotine is an addictive chemical
that's the point
that's the point you don't want to do
this you want to do this you want and
then you want to stop doing that
it's easy lucy dot co promo code hey
babe you're going to get 20
off all products including the gamma
lozenges
your aunt yeah he's quitting my aunt
colleen is quitting because i swear to
god because of lucy
she's been taking the lady's been
smoking for 40 years i'm
i'm finally glad that something positive
is happening to aunt colleen
a sidebar she's a little insufferable
when she doesn't have a cigarette yeah
so now she's thinking that you know
she's eating the lucy.com
she's going to lucy.com lucy's she's
illusion.com
she put in the promo code hey babe she
doesn't know what a podcast is but i
told her put in the promo
you get 20 off and i said but just what
the money is for saving aunt colleen
don't go out buying cigarettes she said
she wouldn't she said she would and now
she has a very pleasant demeanor
yes uh before she was the real pill yeah
she's real pill but lucy dot co babe
lucy dot co
no m promo code hey babe 20 off all the
products including the gum and lozenges
you just see the nicotine alternative
that's what it is all right i'm doing
stand up again
january 16th in the middle of a field in
pennsylvania royersford pennsylvania
heated tent it's going to be great one
show go to christycomedy.com for tickets
or
souljols with an s.com for tickets
souljalls.com
january 16th royersford pennsylvania i'm
doing an hour
it's going to be chaotic it's going to
be wild why not come
it's good there's heaters there they're
going to have beers bring your lawn
chair
it's going to be great january 16th
doing a little stand up maybe i'll
facetime sell
yeah no i know dude there's things that
happen with people like yeah i mean
working in the service industry
i did i ever tell you the time i had
guys i had a guy keel over and died
at the ball while i was working just
clear heal over and paramedics came dead
did you they put the sheet over the body
dead took him out
dead was he a big god what happened
older guy we loved him the pieces he was
a neighborhood guy i think
uh i i guess it was that and then he he
freaking died there
you were yourself it wasn't my shift but
i he was
he was like one of my best friends like
this guy marty old guy marty
and he had his chair end of the bar
middle high life that's where he drank
he sat there
drank he was the color of a plum the day
i met him so
it was going to go south fast i think he
was like 106 and bright purple the day i
met him
and he i thought he would be done by the
end of my first shift but like he lasted
like seven years
how many millions and i came in one day
like marty killed over on his chair then
we
we we made his chair no one could ever
sit there again
and every shift every bartender opened
the middle of his life and put it there
really yeah he just kept it there the
whole day the whole day yeah
how many miller high lifes would he
drink in
one day 12 he would sit he was 15. was
he the guy he'd get there at
noon and stage he opened with me but he
now he was gone for happy hour
once he got crowded like during happy
hour he would leave he would leave
yeah so he would start drinking at noon
but he would come in at night sometimes
too
it could be a 95 degree beautiful day
he's in there drinking miller high life
in the bar
that's where he was on those days yeah
yeah uh he would but he was the best
and like one time there was a bar fight
there was not many right but maybe an
even an altercation and someone pissed
him off he got up and threw a punch
he was 96 he was like he was like in up
there and he threw a punch
god bless him god bless but but we had
people
that would come in and berate us all the
time not that you did that with him but
like
who knows what that guy dealt with
before here i am i'm always playing
devil's advocate for the guy
but no he deserved it he deserved the
cheeseburger in the chest did i ever
tell you about the time when i was a
bartender on the russian boats
[Laughter]
should we rename did i ever tell you
about the time we still don't know
no i this one doesn't ring a bell
especially russian
oh wait something about the bottles
downstairs
no am i getting this right you caught
someone doing something on the boat
that yeah okay so yeah so it's that okay
but and i i'm sure if i told you that
part i much told you the end
uh but i'll say it anyway i was
bartending on my my girlfriend at the
time's uh father's
boats at a sheepshead bay right across
from randazzo's clan bar
and one day we go on and they're like
listen these are some russian mobsters
they're gonna get on the boat
and uh just give them whatever they want
he's the the the
the my girlfriend's father at times
wasn't getting on the boat so i was kind
of like running everything
so i'm up there at the main bar i'm at
the main bar i'm the main bartender me
and this other guy
these russian guys get on the bar like
we're like oh you know what kind of
drinks do you guys like because you know
you kind of cater to the party
he goes oh don't worry my guys will
handle it i'm like oh no where the
bartenders he goes not tonight
and i was like yes we're in the bar
though like we're behind what do you
want us to do
and he goes you're gonna go downstairs
he goes i made a little mini bar
like for the kids for shirley temple and
stuff like that you do that bar this is
just a guy who like
runs the like he paid to come on the
boat he's telling me
what to do that's crazy the boat he goes
we set up a little bar with like sodas
you're just gonna pour drinks and
shirley temples for the russian children
yeah and i was like
okay um i what am i going to do argue
with this right right so okay so with
that i'm just down there i'm like
there's no service on the boat i'm in
the middle of the ward i'm like i guess
i just got to [ __ ] do this
it was also my job to count everybody
who comes on there's like 295 people to
come on
so everybody comes on so i count
whatever 295 you know you have to know
you know two hours into the boat trip
whatever i go in the in a back room
i go in a back room to get to get a uh
crate of something there's a girl on her
knees
guy pants around the ankle she's giving
him hey babe
he with the door open like that opens up
into the party
he doesn't say oh my god what's going on
he goes what do you need
as she's still just wow following him he
goes what do you need what do you need
and i was like it's like a scorsese
movie yeah i was like i need to get i
need to get a crate or whatever he goes
go do it i was like
no should i come back you know like i
didn't know what i was 22 years old he
goes go do it
okay fine so i go do it whatever
i'm like this is the craziest night of
all time yeah then there's a fight
there's like a huge fight
on the boat so you know it's a problem
when there's a huge fight on the boat
obviously there's we had one security
guard it's russian gangsters yeah
whatever whatever
the [ __ ] the the coast guard comes on
the side of the boat we have to hit like
the first minute to hit like a mayday
thing
they come on break it up everything's
fine whatever
we get back into sheepshead bay thing
it's two o'clock in the morning now
have to count everyone out 294. so
oh you told me this yes 294.
holy sh hey babe i say we got a problem
holy hey babe holy hey babe i say we got
a problem
it's 294 there's not i didn't miss count
it's 294 and you know i'm like what's
going on whatever
call the guy who's like in charge of
everything he's like i don't know but
it's russian gangster so i don't want to
get involved
i'm like so i'm 22 years old i'm
supposed to just leave there could be a
murder
could have happened it could be a dead
russian yeah in the water yeah
i don't know okay so i'm like okay i
can't sleep that night whatever
a week later a week later i had a call
from a detective in the nypd were you
kidding were you the bartender on this
boat i said yeah he goes well you know
somebody's missing do you have any
information i said exactly what i did
294 295 there was a fight
blah blah blah never heard anything
about it again never heard of anything
down in the paper
don't know what happened wow somebody
didn't make it off that boat though
somebody went ob
yeah yeah that and that that that story
and then the second second story i have
about bartending on those boats
is well you should do what did i tell
you the story about the wedding the dry
docked wedding
you got to continue it okay you know so
real quick so so
so a lot of times people will get
married on the boat they would get
married on the top level of the boat
because then the boat
you get the ceremony is on is on land
you know so there's not any problems
then you know the ceremony uh the
reception as you go around statue of
liberty blah blah blah
wedding starts 12 o'clock so we get
there 10 o'clock setting up the boat
blah blah blah blah the groom's
everyone's happy you know we're always
waiting for the bride you wait for the
bride because
you know brian makes the entrance that's
anything sure so you know same thing you
see the limo
come down beautiful blah blah blah you
know it's 12 o'clock so whatever yeah
that's 11 55 bride's not there no big
deal
so it happens 12 15 bride's not there
yet you know
captain of the boats like you know
listen can we just check in with her
because obviously of course she wants to
make an edge a little late
but you know by 1 30 we really need to
get out there there's you know dock
space it's a whole business
gas where we're kind of sitting idle no
problem
so 12 15 comes no bride 12 30 no bride
12 45
we see the bride coming we see the limo
coming we see the
white woman come and say thank god she's
there he's saying this is i'm going to
marry this is going to be my life
i'm marrying a woman she's always late i
mean late for a wedding should be late
for a funeral like you know those kinds
of
old-school ginzo jokes brides mom gets
out
bride's mother gets out which is like
okay great it's gonna keep the door open
you know for the long beautiful dress
bride's mom gets out shuts the door
so we're like it's not the bride that's
the bride's mom
bride's mom's walking down i mean the
whole boat is looking the whole she's
walking down like a long thing it's like
the gangway is like going like this
she's yeah she's an older woman
bride's mom comes up tells the
you know first mate or like whoever was
the maitre d i guess say
bride got cold feet she's not coming she
doesn't want to get married
so the the the first mate
uh maitre d guy the first maitre d first
matrid
the first major d gets on the microphone
and says i'm sorry
she's not coming she's like make he's
like
so um you know we're figuring out what
to do we have a plan for this don't
worry i'm so sorry please talk some of
my shelves
with that for whatever reason the
husband or groom
says gets the mic from him and says look
we
we all paid for this wedding this
wedding's paid for the the captain the
guy who owned the boat company was
willing to give him half the money back
which is
pretty good at least she'll get half the
money back he doesn't have to give him
any money back you sign all these
contracts like right
no matter what sure sure he says i feel
terrible after that goes no
keep the money we're having a party it's
supposed to be the best day of my life
it's gonna be the best day of my life
and i'm not gonna do anything else uh
we're gonna have this party we're gonna
rage on
we're like okay i mean as long as it's
okay with you i mean because now it's
just a party on the boat
right most of the wedding party the
groom's wedding party stays
most of the bridesmaids everything the
bridesmaids knew nobody knew that she
was going to do this
they get off if you get on if you a few
stay on if you get off
we take off this guy is pounding
liquor oh my god pounding liquor oh my
god we're about an hour and a half
he's ha he's dancing he's like this is
the best night of my life
things like that pounding liquor at one
point i saw him trying to make out with
a female guest
and she's like stop you're drunk
whatever start going crazy
we're go it was never forget at 6 30 we
always do a lap you do a lap around the
statue it'd be at 6 30 in the summer so
it's beautiful
lights are on he's standing on a couch
like you know by on on the boat standing
on the couch saying this is the best day
of my life
i'm so sorry what happened you know like
whatever we made it work
vanessa you're missing the best guy our
life i love you but i understand what
you did
and it starts he starts yelling goes
like i understand what you did and i
know that was probably wrong and i'm
sorry for the mistakes i made
and starts crying jumps off
[Laughter]
oh my gosh
that is not the first time you saw
someone try to jump to then they'll
you you there's another story
but no wait hold on do you do you think
that he was like when as soon as he
heard she was a company he's like
i'm gonna do this and i'm gonna i'm
gonna jump off yeah and so he was
it was an affront to get everybody on
yeah to do that to
to maybe either deal with the grief or
to stick it to her
that that that he she caused that or do
you think
he just in that moment got caught up and
did it in that moment well the good
i'm hyperventilating the good the good
news is that well not the good news
well well just just so everyone's as you
see he's he survived again coach got it
to come
he survived he could swim we got him out
i have an adrenaline headache right now
dude
hey babe on the trip back we were asking
the same questions to his friends
and most of his friends were like i
don't know this isn't like him whatever
then we're talking some guest at the
wedding who like wasn't a groomsman but
what you know knew them he goes i think
it was my fault
this guy and and i was listening i
wasn't talking directly but an earshot
and then one of the groomsmen was like
what do you mean how could it be your
fault phil
he's like well you know how he doesn't
really drink that much
you know but he was drinking it's his
you know wedding night he just got left
on his wedding night
he said but then i gave him a little
coke
god so he does the first line of coke
he's ever done in his life
on the night his wife doesn't show up
for his own wedding
and jumps off the boat in front of the
statue of liberty
[Laughter]
he could have died could have died oh he
usually could have died hey babe
easily i think it was ted the movie ted
or ted two or ten whatever
and they're like at a they're out of
function and he goes i'll give him one
get
one guys to tell me which guest did coke
and they scan the crowd
and everyone just sit and talk and sit
down and one guy just punches another
guy in the face and jumps out a window
[Laughter]
hey babe oh my god dude that is
crazy my third jump story will save for
another podcast that
that is yeah i mean you do that bit on
stage you crippled me with that yeah
the one that crippled me the one well
yeah with my yeah
yeah yeah yeah that is yeah that's crazy
i'll tell that story
yeah but no dude it's um it's one of
those things where you're working in the
service industry
it's just so you deal with all types of
people i bar attended uh
weddings at uh this place on staten
island called the excelsior grand
it's actually highland yeah yeah it's
actually where i have my high school my
senior prom too
it's been around forever before that's
on my super sweet 16 too that
has it really yeah so it used to be at a
place it used to be the place itself
used to be called the chalamar
it was it was of staten island legend
when we were younger like that was like
the place like it just like spiral
staircase inside things were velvet
right like it was just like a big hall
when you and it had a big glass window
in the front
and when you pass it as a kid you always
like what is this like this big hall
like
you don't really understand and they had
a little person
they used to have employ and he would be
uh he was the greeter
in the circular driveway and he would be
in a tuxedo with tails and like a top
hat
yeah and he would always be out there
and we would pass and like be like oh
look
like the little guy in the tux like yeah
so it felt magical to us right
um as a matter of fact we always thought
a bunch of my friends always thought wu
tang shouted it out
in a song when he says blowing up like
shalamar in 81.
uh it has to be no what we thought it
was and we were like oh my god cause
someone
set the shalamar i think on fire he
caught fire or they tried to blow it up
for insurance money
so we we thought that that's what the
wu-tang reference but we
i looked it up one day because i was
like i gotta know and it actually
is yeah um a reference to seoul shalimar
the group shalamar
who was having like tons of hits that
year tonight to remember like they just
they're an amazing band too but wu-tang
is so smart and
the lyricists are so you know
well-informed that it may have a double
meaning maybe it does
yeah maybe it does yeah uh yeah so
anyway but uh so i worked there so
i was doing weddings every single
weekend is when i first got my
bartending
my first bartending gig and i did
every single cultures wedding right you
know
italian culture greek jewish slavic
russian everything and they all have
their own but like the the slavic like
the russian weddings and like the
jewish weddings there would be like 600
people
like like like 600 minimum right minimum
that's a small one
where they where they when they have a
wedding they would you know like the
place was so huge and they had like the
moving walls
where you could like tailor it to the
size that you need right every
wall from block to block was open and
they would have like 600 800 person
weddings it was wild
and the russian guys man they
like the italian guys will like that
like do me favor and they would give you
like they try to give you
money and everything on the side and um
but the russian guys like
they or some of those guys i remember i
did a wedding one time or maybe it
wasn't russian
but maybe it wasn't russia but they had
a band this is this is two things
the band would play music the entire
time like five hours straight
with hardly stopping and it was like
they would do these songs some of them
that were like
very redundant right so it would be like
the same
chant or the same like riff over and
over and over sometimes for like 40
minutes
and everyone would do this dance
together and it would just be like a
two-step
where they danced and the whole place
was doing it almost like a high school
ladies movie right
and um and the way that they would pay
the band
i don't know if it was a tip i heard
that they don't even pay the band the
band
comes as part of the culture like the
neighborhood like they come that's their
job to like
pay respect to the people that they know
and the band comes and the people
dancing throughout the whole night
singles
in their pocket doing the songs they
just taken they chuck it in the air and
chuck it in the air and chuck it in the
air
and it's 600 people throwing mo like a
hundred singles each
for like a five-hour party to the point
where
we it was dangerous for us as servers
because there was just
it was you couldn't see the floor it was
just singles and then every like
hour we would have to go with a broom
and a garbage bag and just
and just pick up thousands and thousands
give it to the band and just give it
over to the van so that was
unique right but that's sick but one
time this guy came in
and he was like so they would they would
always say uh like
and i'm not don't i don't want to hear
don't send letters to our p.o box
[Laughter]
we don't have an address and i don't
think anyone's handwriting a letter but
what i mean is
don't take offense but but i'm not
saying all russian people but in my
experience at this wedding
um they would like they like if you were
a worker they
treated you like you were they're hired
like butler
and they would talk to you like they'd
be like my friend yeah
and then you walk over and it was like
all couples and they'd be like more of
everything for everyone here
like they'd say stuff like that like i'd
be like well there's a menu
and they were like bring us what you
have yeah and i'd be like well it's core
style and again he's like
come here bring us the food you have now
and i'd be like i just walk in the back
i be like look
like they're demanding everything now
yeah and then i just bring it out but
then like if their
girlfriend like or something like they
like again they just beckon you
right they go oh friend yeah and then
you'd walk over and he'd be like
mo so they wanted buckets of beers on
the table okay
so buckets of beers and ice which is not
how you really do it at a wedding
not at a really formal event no yeah
we're not in the parking lot
jets game they drink and they have then
they want then they start going we want
bottles on the table
right which is i think customary for
russians okay as a matter of fact
it is but when you're in a place that is
like doesn't always do that they didn't
ask for it first and then they decided
they want it so they're like
bring two bottles of vodka and bring
more buckets of beer more and they would
so what we did then was we served nips
okay so if they wanted the actual beer
we normally had to pour a beer
but they had them in the nip so the nips
is like a eight ounce or a little six
ounce beer
so they would pound them right so like
by the time i brought a bucket we're
talking 800 people so
they would assign like uh i think it was
a
a bartender to every 100 people whatever
it was
which is or maybe even more than that
150. so we had our work cut out for us
and the place they told us if someone
has to come to your station
for a drink you're not doing your job so
you need to get the drinks to the tables
and by the time they want another one if
they're getting up to you you're not
going fast enough
so it was unreasonable to ask of the
workers
at 150 people like 10 tables six tables
each but
that made me hustle like that really
taught me how to bartend so i would run
and do a run
by the time i dropped off eight nips at
a table of
eight or whatever it is they would be
done so everyone was just yelling at me
from every table
my friend more beard more beard for
everyone and they'd just be like that
and i'm like yeah yeah okay okay
and then i'd come and they'd be like
they'd like take it upon me
like they'd be like what about my wife
and i'd be like what do you want and
she'd be like what do you want
and then he'd tell her and he'd like go
get martini and i'd be like
okay go get it go get it i'd be like i
thought you wanted to be i didn't know
it was no thank you
go get it so i'm like whatever just i'm
it's my job to be
i'll just listen it's not like you know
i take it in stride so i'm bringing
everything over
this happened a lot yeah and then and
then one time i learned my lesson
so one time i'm gonna be proactive i
turn to the woman and i go
uh is there anything i can get you and
she was like
and i was like okay is there anything i
can get you and she's like
no and i was like okay and i went to the
next one i go can i get you
anything and then a guy touch me on the
show like oh he goes come here
he takes me in the corner he goes do not
talk to the women
and i was like oh i was just asking them
because you know how you said before
like what about my wife so he goes no no
you don't talk to the women and i was
like how do i know what they want he
goes
do not and i go okay yes and then i
never spoke to another woman now hold on
now the bride the bride comes out right
the bride and the groom are
at the deus alone this guy is standing
on his seat of the deus and he has four
coronas in his hand
two in each he's drinking he's going
like this
people are whipping singles his bride
again i don't know if this is the
culture not this their relationship no i
don't know what it is
this is how it was she was sitting no
drink
head down now not head down like this
but just like
like just sitting calmly like maybe she
was having a zen moment
maybe that wasn't her style maybe he was
getting out of control maybe she was
embarrassed
but it just seemed like she was way more
like
let me just sit here because this is how
i do it yeah
this is how he does it right but the
bride we're taught like there's a the
suite where you go like the the
the suite up before you start there all
the people the important people go in it
like the bridal sweep
before they everyone comes the bridal
suite gets there first
and we're serving them food and drinks
the same thing they're like you don't
make anyone ask
anything in their brother the bride he
goes drop everything
for the bride and groom the door should
be open yeah
drop everything for the bride and groom
especially the bride
so this guy has four beers in his hand
he's standing on the chair and he's
doing the macarena
whatever he's doing and so i leaned in
and i said excuse me miss
like is there anything i could do for
you at all ten guys swarmed me
grabbed me and dragged me to the side
dragged you they i mean
i mean not like like like like you're
gonna throw me up on my body suit but
like
i mean i was in the middle of speaking
and they came over they all go come on
come on come on
hold my arms and guarded me away and
brought me over there we said
we told you donato you don't ever talk
to the bride and i was like i'm really
sorry i was like i don't i don't mean to
do anything but like i
don't mean it didn't mean anything by it
but like my job is you guys paid
for service and i i did i'm just making
sure that the
the bride and they they were like no and
then they were like don't
don't ever come up to them again for the
rest of the wedding who your boss told
you
no no the russian guys or the people
they told me
i feel like i've never heard that it
feels like a wedding for isis i i i
should have gotten it
i was just like wow this is going back
to
how we said when the guy was like you
didn't order three
i just thought of customer service and i
thought of the flip side of that and
here i am working
and this these are the people that hired
us but like how do you respond to
something like that
dude that's i'm telling you it was wild
dude did i ever tell you
about the time when i first started
comedy with uh when i did the
the back-to-back gigs in what one night
for the italian mafia the next night for
the
for the um for the uh backyard barbecue
party so real quick
i uh yeah i was doing the gig i started
comedy 2009.
i do this gig this is i started comedy
october 2009 this is
maybe january 2010 maybe february 2010
so three four months in you know
comedy's horrible
angel salazar the comedian angel salazar
from scarface
sees me at caroline she's like i got a
gig for you so we're gonna go it's it's
you know it's kind of mafia guys we're
gonna do it i said okay
so we go do the gig i suck i open up for
him
i do some joke that offends some mafia
guy's wife i had no idea
that i even offended his wife i get off
st
i could see i could hear like a pin drop
i i was bombing
i get off stage somebody grabs me one of
these like big mafia
henchmen grabs me puts a knife to my
throat like a full knife to my throat
and says i quote
i'm gonna cut your adam's apple out and
feed it to your mother so i was like
okay
so he said he said he's gonna cut my abs
out feed it to my mother with that the
owner
of the place i think the place was
called scungilis or something like that
on left foots boulevard in queens
it's definitely shut down now shout out
to leftovers boulevard queens
so yes you oh friday this is wild
so you put i mean what are you thinking
in that moment when i was thinking at
that moment i was like i'm going to die
for to to be an open mic comedian i'm
going to lose my life did you possibly
think you could right
because someone's going gonna do that to
you and you're not really you're not
really used to that kind of experience
to be
treated like you your body like you
don't know if it's real if it's not if
it's a threat you hear about these
senseless acts of violence all the time
all the time and so and and so the owner
of the bar both guys name were carmine
the guy who held this knife to my throat
was carmine and the guy who owned it was
named carmine because the carmine
the owner says to carmine the other guys
i carmine put the knife down
walk away so carmine the owner grabs me
and he takes me down like some he takes
me to his what i think is his office
and then moves a bookshelf and there's a
door behind the bookshelf that exits out
onto the street
so i was like okay so i don't know
what's gonna happen he's like look don't
tell anybody about this that guy's a
wannabe
he causes problems here he goes what
were you supposed to get paid i said
angel is going to give me 25
he gives me 2 000 in cash that he pulled
out of his back pocket
he goes take this just don't tell nobody
what happened here sure because
you got that's someone threatened to
murder you that person would go to jail
and he was whole established when he get
shut down he's probably selling drugs
out of the back of it
right so that two thousand dollars cash
cash what are you thinking
in that moment in that moment i'm saying
should you take it should you not
i'm saying at that moment i'm saying it
this is dirty money
i shouldn't spend it fast forward spend
that shouldn't spend it fast forward
next week but took it
but i took it yeah fast forward you got
it yeah i i had about 10 new pairs of
jordans
i went absolutely
that is some guy in a ditch for that
money so that's so that's friday night
you would think like some people like oh
get a knife to my throat it's like
that'll never you'll never
your life will never be threatened again
in comedy just happened whatever i have
a show the very next day
at an outdoor barbecue the outdoor
barbecue shows are brutal this is on
northern boulevard
in queens i'm doing a joke there's a guy
again i suck at comedy i still do but
this time i
this i really suck i i i um
i'm doing a joke this guy's got tattoos
all over his head and his face
i don't know anything i'm new i make a
joke
to the guy with the tattoos on his face
like oh what are you a kindergarten
teacher something stupid
with that he starts breathing hard
starts punching himself in the face
in the chest so so yeah
like what is going on what is going on
he's punching himself
in the face there was children already
got face tattoos he's he's he's
made plenty of decision in his life that
weren't the right decision he starts
beating the crap out of himself
to because he's so enraged so enraged he
can't believe that somebody called out
on him
so enraged so his friends his friends i
mean do you i mean
yeah go ahead continue but i just run
off the stage his friends who all they
all look like gang bangers his friends
and gang members start backing away from
him as if to say
look the other guys are real hard and
criminal guys even they're like i don't
want
when when caesar gets like this you got
to step away so he starts punching
himself in the face
i put the mic i was in the middle of a
joke it's like dead i put the
yeah it's like your 10th spot ever
it's a backyard barbecue i put the mic
back in the stand
walk off stage let's climb over the
fence exit through the neighbor's
backyard
because you're coming off the heels of
the knife enough tonight i'm like what
am i doing
it's a it's a wonder that we know each
other and you're here today yeah that
you continued in comedy continue to do
it
my friend joey g had put the gig
together he got me joey g of joey g
joey g joey g from the weddings from the
guy that taped all the weddings
no no he's famous here i know joey
comedian guy i think he quit
too joey g but anyway yeah so i climb
over the
in front of everyone like i put the mic
in the stand yeah they say give it up
for chris instead of walking out past it
with the way out you will not go i'm all
i wouldn't even think of
of even going anywhere near him i scaled
the fence
and jumped out through a neigh the
neighbor could have a pitbull i didn't
care in that moment
i gotta get away from this guy with that
so i leave i'm like that was the
craziest thing back to back nights
i'm doing stand up i couldn't believe
friday i almost died saying i almost
died
i get a call sunday afternoon from
another nypd detective
he says were you the comedian on stage
last night
around six o'clock and i said yes i was
you know i i i climbed out i
i don't know if i broke some personal
property i explained the whole story he
goes it's not about that
he goes about 45 minutes after you left
the man you made a joke on
went and murdered someone in broad
daylight on the street a random guy
crossing the street
he murdered him so people were saying
that he was pissed off because of the
joke you made
so we part of our investigation we want
to know what the joke was
holy hey babe hey babe hey babe
sorry holy hey babe holy hey babe so
somebody went and murdered
a random stranger because i pissed them
off in a comedy show
and i said am i going to have to testify
like i don't want to be a part of the
city no they said we just
want to know so you know we're tracking
things down basically what the
then i got a call maybe three months
later when they were tying up this thing
a guy had already went back to jail they
said yeah what happened was is you know
throughout the
he didn't even there was no trial he
just pled guilty he had just gone out of
prison a week before
and was not adjusting to the freedom of
the new world because he had done like
20 years
he wanted a reason to go back to prison
and you gave him that reason
oh my god yeah holy hell hey
all my dates christy comedy.com
that is wild oh my god dude
look i don't care if i'm kimbo slice
yeah if i'm bruce lee if i'm talking to
somebody who starts hitting himself
first yeah
i'm not engage i'm not i'm gonna hop the
back vents too yeah i i mean
that death's not on you as casually as
i'll walk down your
feeling did you ever feel that death was
on you because you shouldn't no
i do i feel terrible about it but you
know the the the
it was like yeah i never felt that i
just kind of felt like i can't believe i
even did comedy i did comedy monday at
the creek could you imagine though could
you imagine
yeah the guy who died's family
and the police were like
a couple of minutes prior a comedian
asked him what are you a kindergarten
teacher with those face tattoos
yeah and we're sorry to say that's what
drove him
to to take your your whoever this was
out of your
your family they and to this day those
people want to know who told that joke
who was it
i mean if they're watching now do you
want to say something to them if you
guys are watching now
i really apologize my comedy has gotten
better since then and i think it'd be
safe for you and your family you can't
blame him you can't blame him i can all
but
i'm not even making a light of this i
mean this is tragic if you're watching
right now but
we can laugh about it now we can laugh
about it now but i can guarantee you i'm
looking in the camera whoever you are
i can guarantee you that if you come to
one of my comedy shows
i i am going to give you as close to 100
as i can
that no one will see my comedy and then
proceed
to immediately murder an innocent
stranger
i'm confident that my jokes will not
allow someone to do that i thought
you're going to say i'm going to give
you as much as i can 100 off the bill
listen or if you buy two drinks i got
how did you stick with comedy i'm
insane that is not so that's what it is
baby that's nuts that's nutso and then
yeah speaking of nutshell
sour together springs pizza to the
beginning bring it back if you're
watching this
we want to be what do we want five ten
percent five ten percent or we'd like a
hey bay peanut butter uh named after us
that would be wonderful why don't we do
that let's do that let's
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna reach out
to them let's reach out so i gotta reach
out to a few people shout out to them
yolanda vega
and lori have a good day everybody
hey babe hey babe
hey babe